okay i'd like to go ahead and and start
with this
bill we have before us in the committee
of conference it's 1421 an act relative
to lead in school drinking water
um today we have with us
uh
from the senate once you introduce
yourself aaron then come in round two
good morning aaron hennessey senate
district one
cindy rosenwald senate district 13. ruth
ward senate district eight
and i'm rick ladd i'm from haverhill
representative
sandwich
art ellison merrimack 27
six awards here in concord
bill nelson carroll county district 5.
welcome
so on on 1421 we had does everybody have
a the side by side which was brought
down here today
um i think the
the uh
as this past the house with the house
version we all unanimously concur and
we're very supportive our are
identifying the lead and drinking water
um
with the the senate version there are
some questions and many mainly it's we'd
like to have some information from des
if we may be so we start right out could
you please explain to us the
appropriation of seven point plus
million dollars where that comes from
how that works
um we understand
that as when we pass this bill there is
roughly around 120 000 dollars set aside
for us staff over at the department to
monitor
uh the and put into the database the
information that comes back from the
school districts guarding leading their
water in the after several rounds et
cetera and we understand where that
dollar comes from to do the analysis of
the water
in is that a separate grant from the
infrastructure grant that we're talking
about here we're just
a little bit lost on that
yep okay hi my name is leanne atwell and
i work at des and i am the program
manager for the lead in school and child
care facility drinking water program uh
the the
7.6 7.76 million dollars is
unrelated to the lead in school and
drinking water program it is related to
a
matching
fund that is needed for state revolving
loan fund
funding
that would come as part of the
bipartisan infrastructure law
there's a requirement that the state
provide matching funds so that we can
get approximately 20 million dollars
from the federal government for state
revolt for the state revolving loan fund
and the drinking water that'll fund
drinking water
infrastructure improvements across the
state
so i have a question for you the when we
got a letter from robert scott
um
there was mention to the u.s epa water
infrastructure
improvement for the nation grant
w i i n i guess
is that the money is that where the
money is coming from for the analysis of
the water that's correct so today we've
seen
des has received approximately two
million dollars through that grant
program and that'll be used for testing
it is also being used for outreach and
education
and it's being used to
to fund
my position which is a part-time
temporary position to manage the program
thank you
are there questions of the department
from any
folks
are our answers
okay go ahead represent cordelia
thank you thank you for being here
so um if i understand correctly this is
matching dollars and this
uh money would be coming from a warrant
authorized by the governor from the
general fund
and appropriated in the next biennium
is that correct
no how does that work senator it's the
fiscal year that begins this july first
okay but it is general funds general
funds yep
are there
further questions that was the reason
why the house called the committee a
conference to
try to figure out how the seven million
dollars interacted here
um
any further discussion on this
yes representative ellison
thank you for taking my question so i as
i understand it the 7.7
million if it came from the general fund
would be a match against 7.7 million of
federal money am i interpreting that
correctly i think the the
sum coming from the federal would be 21
million
so it's it's a you know it's not a
one-to-one match but it's a contribution
that
is required thank you
is there any more discussion regarding
1421.
okay so the
obviously the senate version is the
version which contains the the
funds for the revolving fund the the
matching dollars
is there any opposition from committee
members on the house side here to
seating to the senate
position
if if i may i'm not sure
des had also sent an email about the
floor amendment that was added on on the
senate floor i'm not sure
if if you had received that i have
copies of that that i can hand out if
that's helpful
sure
so the
the version of the bill that you have in
front of you uh the the text that is
shown
in
red is the text that was the amendments
that were made
on the on the floor amendment when the
senate was when the senate took up hb
and
des would recommend going back to the
version that passed out of the education
and finance committees and that text is
shown in blue
just so you can see the differences
um
we have concerns that that the the floor
amendment would essentially
make the
the
option to
install bottle filling stations
difficult to implement
the first part of the amendment had
changed the requirement to install
bottle filling stations within 180 days
of bill passage and
just a couple of things regarding that
that time frame you know most schools
have already set their budgets for the
coming year and so if they've not
already planned and budgeted for that
they wouldn't have the funds set aside
to
to put in bottle filling stations
and then also you know we've been
noticing on our other projects some
supply chain
and issues and contractor availability
uh just in terms of you know all of the
the projects going on right now so
we do have some concerns about that
180-day time frame just being
you know the practicality of actually
being able to to install bottle filling
stations in that time frame
and then the next part of the amendment
on the next page
uh paragraph c
originally the way the the bill was
written as it passed out of the
education and finance committee
committees in the senate was that if
bottle filling stations were installed
then other outlets such as classroom
sinks and bathroom sinks that weren't
used for consumption could be posted as
not being suitable for
consumption
and the amendment essentially requires
that if you put in bottle filling
stations that you would still test all
of the bathroom and cloth bathroom sinks
and classroom sinks in a facility and so
essentially makes the bottle filling
station option um you know not very
practical
you know the intention of the bottle
filling station option was to be able to
provide
more flexibility to schools so they
could install those stations instead of
testing 30 50 sinks within a building um
and really directs students to those
bottle filling stations as to be you
know those are the locations where they
should get their water rather than
classroom and bathroom sinks
represent cordelia and then represent uh
senator dependency
thank you just going back to the 7.7
million
briefly
is there a deadline
for the state to provide the
matching funds in order to get the full
grant from the federal government
i don't know the answer to that i'm
sorry
i would imagine there is i know you know
we're working on um work plans right now
for that funding so i imagine there is a
deadline but i'm sorry i don't know off
the top of my head second or do you want
to go senator hennessey
thank you uh just to send uh
representative cordelli's question
i i don't know what the deadline is but
i imagine there was and that's why we
had to add it in the senate when we
found out about them um a question for
leanne um
so the reason why we added the 180 days
on the senate side is because if you
follow through the logic of options here
and you've identified that you have a
lead issue in a school
if you don't put a timeline on the ins
on this installation of the water
filling stations
i and you're choosing the water bottle
filling station as your option to
remediate i don't see where
there's any time frame for remediation
do you understand where we're going out
on that yeah yep
yep i under i under i can see i can see
the you know where that was coming from
i just i think the 180 days might be a
little
um
might be a little too too soon just
given the budget the budget constraints
for schools
senator rosenwald
thank you just following up on senator
hennessey's point
the water bottle filling stations are
not required
they're an option
for schools so
a school that does not
have the budget is not required
to have a water bottle filling station
would you agree
right it's not a requirement but it's
just an option that they can choose to
do that instead of testing and keeping
track of you know multiple
multiple outlets
and if i could follow up yes
on the your your second
um blue section
um
the senate was concerned
that even if
a
school did
decide to
have the water bottle filling station
there would still be water
that children could have access to
elsewhere in the school
and since the whole point of this bill
is to
keep children safe from lead in their
drinking water
the senate thought it was important to
say
you still have to test the other
outlets
for the presence of lead if children
have access
to those outlets
does that make sense to you and i think
the
you know the um
i think the
the concept is that if you put the
bottle filling stations in then at those
other sinks they would be clearly marked
as not suitable for drinking water and
students would not be allowed to to use
those so if you had a sink in a
classroom that hadn't been tested that
you know that would be part of the
process is that students shouldn't be
filling their water bottles up there
they should be directed to fill them up
at the at the water bottle filling
stations
even if they can't read
yeah that's right well they make you
know there are signs that you know that
are that are graphics that
that could be used
thank you
representative cornelli
thank you um
i believe where we are is that we have
been presented with the senate amendment
that includes
um all their amendments
so if we were to want to consider the
language just prevent presented to us
that was
i guess
um prior to some of the senate
amendments
on the language in blue on this document
um am i correct that that would have to
be
an amendment to this uh committee yes at
this point
that we'd have to have an amendment just
drawn up to reflect what's on here
for new construction are the schools
mandated to have bottle uh facilities in
a new building i understood in the
legislation we've previously seen that
they would be required to have these
facilities in a new construction
i believe there was a bill and i'm not
sure of the status maybe it was
sb 599 that was taken up the session
that would require bottle filling
stations and new construction but i've
not been following that i'm not sure
what happened to remember it
yes senator sherman's bill i don't know
the number
we passed that
so
um
uh chairman lad it's still i i
understand the concern for the um
for the budget-wise and for the um
the the material shortages that were
have going on right now
but i have a concern
not so much for the second change
proposal on the second page but the
first page
if we don't put a time constraint in
when they choose that option
because
they either take option a or they take
option b
and so if they take option a and they
just never do anything about it because
they're not required to install them by
a certain amount of time then they're
not testing and they're not remediating
and we we don't know if there's lead
that the kids are being exposed to
and we don't know
if they have clean drinking water so if
we don't have a time frame in there then
they actually haven't chosen to do
anything if they've not installed a
water bottle filling station does that
make sense yes
okay so
so is the 180 days that's
here um
are you advocating to change that or
i'm i'm advocating to keep the time
frame in because if the school doesn't
have the budget or can't
when they are choosing to go that route
keeping in mind that schools are already
supposed to been testing
this is not something new that they are
supposed to be doing
so if they haven't actually tested yet
this would leave them option of
doing something
when they can raise the funds to put in
but they would wouldn't have actually
tested
their water sources to know that they
have lead or don't have lead so i'm i'm
in favor of keeping the 180 days and if
a school cannot choose that route for
the water bottle filling station they
have the alternative route
of testing
and remediating
which could be just capping
or bringing
bottles of water in or
or fixing the pipes yep
well i concur with what you're saying
so are are you saying that you're good
with this amendment the way it is
i am definitely good with 180 days i'm
open to discussion on the second page
and maybe represent senator rosenwald
i
completely agree with you
that we need to have
time parameters
on installing the water bottle filling
stations
if that's the route
the school is chosen to take in fact
that
180 days it's consistent with
on the top of page two
which says if you've already installed
the water bottle filling stations you
have to test them within 180 days but
senator hennessey is absolutely right
otherwise a school could say we're going
to go water bottle filling station but
we're never we're just not going to get
around to it because
there's no timing required
on when we
act and and that doesn't seem to make
sense
i think that the language
um
in blue is more protective of children
the testing for water is not expensive
23 000 tests
have already been conducted
in schools
um
over the last few years it's 90 plus
percent
of schools have already tested
once
um
well i don't think it's
as critical i think it's
i think it's more protective of children
than just labeling an outlet not for
drinking water the sign could
fall down
disappear
i would think that a community would
want to know if their kids are being
poisoned by lead in the drinking water
isn't the present time frame correct me
if i'm wrong i thought it was june 30th
that you had funds to pay for the
analysis of these checks which you're
talking about
and that is enough money there to
support two rounds of checking i
understand
is that being done now by schools
that's correct we have the funding for
it it's available to public schools and
licensed child care facilities
yes so we've not started the round of
testing the next round of testing yet
we're waiting to see what happens with
this legislation before we you know roll
out testing and um you know want to make
sure that there's clear direction on
what you know what happens on the back
end um so but we do anticipate that that
would start later and is the database up
and running so that you can get the
rechecks put into the database
yes
and okay that's a good question didn't
we appropriate 1.6 million dollars
several years ago
in fact only about 70 something thousand
of that has been expended so far
yes so the 1.6 million dollars came from
the drinking water and groundwater trust
fund and was a grant to department of
new hampshire department of education to
um to help schools with remediation
projects and that's a 50
reimbursement
process so the schools pay for the pay
for the work and then they can apply for
the grants and get reimbursed 50 percent
and you're right not very much money of
that has been spent and we think a lot
of it is the timing you know the program
was really getting going right before
the pandemic started and schools have
been focused on other things and we've
since hired an outreach contractor
that's actually going through and
reaching out to schools that are
eligible and encouraging them to apply
so we hope that
you know hope to make that process
easier for schools
but
almost all of the money
is still available to schools
correct i think so far about 78 000
i don't know the exact number but in
that ballpark has been spent thank you
so looking at this amendment and i'm
reading the top part says the language
modified by amendment 1839 s on the
senate floor needs to be restored and
provisions 1839
need to be removed the language that
needs to be removed is shown in red the
language that needs to be restored is
shown in blue so if we follow that
the way it's put out does what has to be
changed if anything has to be changed to
accomplish what you're trying to
accomplish senator hennessey
or rosenwald
the time frame
i'm sorry i didn't understand
i think for me
i would not agree with
the proposed change that's on page one
i would just leave it as amended by the
senate
and then i would like to confer with my
senate colleagues on the proposed change
on page number two
so would you like to just take a short
caucus and do that
sure i think we have a little bit of
time here
over across the street now cheers
tonight to be meeting right you have a 9
30.
can you take about five minutes uh
senator and trying to square that up or
direct one of the others to
make it work
a
as it is
okay
thank you mr chair so the senate would
like to maintain its position with the
red language on page number one yes
and then on page number two
understanding that there may be some
confusion around
what outlet a kid might have access to
we're not intending
to test
janitor closet
water faucets here we're intending to
test
if there's a faucet in the in the in the
um classroom where a kid could fit
easily the child has access yep so um
and maybe you guys can give me comments
on this so so change the red language
that we have
um remove the word such as to to
including so water from other outlets
available to children including
classroom and bathroom sinks and water
outlet dudes for preparing food
preparation shall be tested and
remediated if necessary per the
provisions in paragraph 3. so removing
such as
input including
so because recognizing that such as
could be a little vague
question
yes
question um in the proposed blue
language um in c um you would not add
the last sentence about uh food
preparation water
you're just looking at
um the let's say the side by side c
and just making the one change of um
such as to including
what's happening that last sentence in
the blue on that second page
water used for food preparation shall be
done exclusively through the use of
water bottling filling stations if such
outlet has not been tested and
remediated is that fine the way it is
you want to have that outlet
in the kitchen
check for sure
so maybe that's you're objecting to that
no i'm just uh
questioning i'm uh i was a little
confused by the language in the in that
sentence anyway yeah
so the red language does have water
outlets used for food preparation shall
be tested and remediated if necessary
so the remediation could include
capping it and putting in water bottle
filling station or could
it could be fixing the pipe or putting a
filter in
so in summary then you're offer
on the first page there
keeping the original language of the
senate
and then on page two
uh changing the words such as to
including classroom bathroom sinks
et cetera
correct
now
we i how how is the you know the house
uh in regard to the proposed change
right here from the senate
good
we're acceptable to that
so i guess what we where we are right
now is that
are we going to approve based upon the
language we're approving here right now
and get an amendment made
or having the amendment made and then
coming back and approving the amendment
that would be up to you mr chairman
because in the senate we do committee
amendments
[Laughter]
um since we're only adding one word
it's up to you well
yeah we're adding a yeah one word
maybe
maybe i could ask grant what what we
would need to do
yeah because we were so close you know
and and
some of us have a multitude of
conferences still ahead of us are behind
us even
grant bossie new hampshire senate uh
it's a house bill generally the house
would write the report you just write
the report however you want to write it
and that's the version that gets signed
off on
okay so you don't need to formally adopt
the introduction
we don't need another meeting i think
that we can all agree upon what we've
done right here
um senator
you're good with that absolutely okay so
it looks like we're all concurrent so
you're agreeing and we're agreeing to
the senate version as amended with our
changes here
yes
i think we are done
thank you very much
okay jen
one two three four yep four bucks
three over there okay we're good to go
okay i'd like to welcome everybody to
today's committee of conference dealing
with hb 1639 this is an act relative to
the youth risk behavior survey in
schools
we have two versions there's a side by
side
maybe perhaps what we'll do is introduce
ourselves for the public so they know
who's sitting here uh senator khan can
we start with you and just work right
around the table
we'll do uh senator jay kahn uh
president of keene and representing 15
of 23 towns in cheshire county
aaron hennessey senator from district
one
ruth ward district 8 24 towns
representative rick ladd from haverhill
representative glenn cordelli
representing tufton borough
moultonborough and sandwich
representative ralph bowm litchfield
representative deb hobson from
rockingham 35
thank you
okay so everybody has a copy of the side
by side here and there's uh two
positions
i'm sure you've all read that and
familiar with the positions
um
is there do we have any kind of an
amendment yet amendment yet uh
on anything here no okay
let's work our way down through it um
the
i guess the concern the largest concern
would be whether it's opt out or opt
in
that would be probably you know the
primary and the house version is to opt
in
and the
senate version is to keep it the way it
is now
discussion representative cordelli
uh thank you mr chairman
i think the other
important thing in the uh house version
is that it requires a local school
district um
board uh approval of the survey before
it's it's given
um
and just in in general about the survey
this is supposed to be a survey related
to health related behaviors um according
to the cdc
um
department of health and human services
has said this is a survey about
healthy behavior
and when you start the survey
it
indicates that this is to measure the
percentage of youth who practice risky
health behaviors
but i went through the past couple of um
yrbs high school surveys and just want
to read a couple of the questions from
that
this is from 2017
during your life with whom have you had
sexual contact
includes males females females and males
i think some would question whether
that's uh risky behavior
which of the following best describes
you heterosexual gay or lesbian bisexual
or not sure
during the past 12 months have either of
your parents
or other adults in your family been in
jail or in prison i'm not sure what that
has to do with a student's healthy
behaviors
during the past 12 months
have you talked to at least one of your
parents about dangers of tobacco health
or drug use
do you this is a great one do you or do
you have someone in your family who is
currently in the military
or no why is that on a question about
healthy behaviors if you're if you've
got a parent or a sibling in the uh
military that's ridiculous
um
um how wrong
do you
do
your parents feel it would be for you to
have one or two drinks of an alcoholic
beverage nearly every day
um
from 2019
some of the same questions
um
uh
how do you describe yourself underweight
overweight about right etc
uh
during your life how often has there
been an adult in your household who
tried hard to make sure your basic needs
were met such as looking out for your
safety making sure you're sure you had
clean clothes
and enough to eat
again
are either of your parents
in your family serving on active duty in
the military
those are some of the questions and i i
think that
they have nothing to do
with uh someone's um risky behavior or
not um we've seen just within the past a
few weeks
the state of florida has uh
indicated they will cease
using the cdc yrbs survey they will come
up with their own survey instead
um
i i think that uh
uh the parents have a right to know um
about these surveys
um
i know there have been provisions about
contacting i think that that
in many cases uh does not happen
and i think that
according to the house version
i am fully
supportive of making this an opt-in uh
just as every other survey um that um
contains questions um along these lines
um are um in current law
um so i am in full support of the the
house version
further discussion on this
uh represent boom yeah thank you
received a letter an email which all the
others have too but it's from a doctor
and
his comment is based on well the
incident in institutional review board
and he said the current use risk
behavior survey would not pass
irb muster for several reasons
it is not a metric proven to give
reliable information it is not
controlled except by measuring the
current data against the data from two
years ago
the
rbs had not been shown to be reliable
and moreover it's its questions are
potentially harmful
because they can create confusion in the
children's mind plant ideas that may not
have occurred to them and invade the
privacy in a way that parents may not
approve
it's an experiment with no
defined goal and there's more but and
basically it should be opt in that's
what my bill had said and we've been
fighting this for years
and more so um
it'll be fought in the next few years
also because it's definitely it's a bad
survey
this one at least two-thirds of the
students don't answer it correctly
it's a joke to them it's not anonymous
but the first seven questions you can
pretty much determine who the student is
and to my thing it should be just
abolished period just like when
florida's doing okay so anyway um
are there any points in
in in various versions that we can come
to
agreement on
um
i'll start it out perhaps by saying i do
concur with the idea that a 14-day
notice is better than
what we previously have in there of 10
days notice of letting parents be
notified and getting this
out to them
that it's going to be administered in
the school and it can be done
electronically or by written
is there anybody objects to that portion
no okay so i i think we can jump by that
there's another portion that was in the
uh board uh in the uh house
version said that the local school
district board shall annually approve
the youth risk behavior survey
i'd like to just address that for a
second
putting it at the local level
to make that decision
whether they're going to go forward with
this or not it would be a decision of
the select board or not select by the
school board
um
so can we have a little discussion on
that please yes represent a question
do you have any
sorry do you have any idea how often
that has happened that a local school
board has actually said no we're not
going to do the survey
i don't have that information i don't
know it's if it's even been done
i know that the survey is received by
department of education and they
have a bank questions which they can use
and they go through it and some they
take some they don't take and they
that's what we use in the state
but then it's funneled down to the
districts to administer
uh in accordance with statute that we
have um
i don't believe that the decision has
been made no we're not going to do that
by a school board i haven't heard of
that i've read about that
um
this is what
the house version proposes
that
um
the local school district board shel
shall annually
make a decision whether we're moving
forward with it or not
yes
okay then i spoke with i believe she was
a clinician yesterday had a very lengthy
conversation
and she said that in the beginning of
the school year each family they get
a letter
telling them what might happen during
the school year and then write
a blanket permission
and that was assumed to be permission
for whatever the school decided to do
including the surveys
and that question wouldn't it be better
to get in touch with the parents before
or closer to the time you have a server
when you know that a lot of parents are
objecting to it
and
she said i might be nice but they
by signing this letter they had actually
given permission for the school to do
whatever needed to be done during the
school year
further discussion
go ahead
i i certainly
would be very concerned about uh any
kind of blanket
permission
from a parent
done at the
start of the school year and i am not
sure if
any local school boards
do a review
to approve or disapprove of the survey
i'm not aware of that because it it is
not required in current law
so i've just handed out a sheet of paper
and i don't think i had enough to go
around all the way but i'll read
if
if this is a consideration at all
i would suggest that it be added to and
we accede to the senate version but add
into it
language which which would say the local
school district board shall annually
approve the risk behavior survey and
upon approval parents shall be provided
the opportunity to review the
questionnaire
prior to distribution of the survey
students shall be reminded that euthyris
survey is voluntary
that is language which i would suggest
that would come from the from the house
side to and we would accede to the
senate version
as amended
perhaps
also i have a problem with the senate
version also with the language where it
removes that it's a senate a cdc
survey
and it also
lower cases use risks i mean that's the
name of the survey and it shouldn't be
in lower case but don't that's my
concern with the senate version also
they're not mentioning that it's a
center for the disease control
survey
which i think is definitely needed
the red version left out the word youth
it's youth risk behavior survey was done
very rapidly
um
so there's several issues that have been
brought up uh
senator ward i'll just have a comment
because i think in the senate version
you'll find
that written and electronic verification
and also talks about for review by
students parents
your bank's not on center
in the
proposed amendment that we have
it's very similar to what's already in
the senate version
school did this district make such
surveys question available at the school
and and on the school in the school
district's website for review by
students parents and legal guardian
and provide in addition provide written
electronic notification to addresses
known by the district at the time of
notification prior to distribution to
students
so it seems to me that's already covered
in the senate version
what uh the house
suggested language here is that
the survey be approved by the local
school board and upon approval then that
approved survey would be available
uh for parental review of that
questionnaire
so it's it's uh not sayings that you can
just hand it out as maybe it comes down
from doe
you'd have to approve it as a board and
then to
go that direction
senator khan
do you anticipate that this would
impact the
reporting on a statewide basis
i can't project but i can give you my uh
opinion that
if this survey is so important
that we
administer it
on a
opt-out basis to students of which i
know many parents at home never received
that survey never review the survey
and just
school says do it we do it they comply
um i i think if it's that important that
for all these agencies and organizations
which have said we use this information
and not quibbling with that i understand
then it's it's important enough then
that the person that we're serving the
child
which the the
guardian and legal guardian of that
child
is the parent
or maybe the state
that the
they should have the opportunity also to
you know through their elected
representation decide whether we want
this
administered or not administered and
it's important enough that when you do
it at a local board meeting then
it's more notice is going to be going
maybe the committee said we love it we
want it
but i can't tell you whether it would
change your statistics your outcomes or
not i do know that
information i read uh must mean about
seven or eight years ago regarding this
when we first started talking about this
is that the statistical difference
between opt out and opt-in doesn't
change it enough so it ruins the the
outcome of the survey
and i've heard people say oh no that's
not so but that the data i looked at
just said that it's just that that you
will see fewer responses of course if
it's opt in however the the outcomes are
still
pretty much within three or four points
of of where it would have been doing it
by
uh opt out
uh mr chairman i just to continue there
the two things uh one i think that
that's
been
addressed in testimony
the difference in participation rates
are fast
uh
between an 85 to 90 percent
participation rate versus a 30
participation rate that's pretty
significant to me
and secondly
we have heard from
our significant state agencies the
health and human services and education
that this is an important statewide
marker
i think we want to know if we are
looking like west virginia or florida or
a neighboring new england states
and
uh
that's what this
survey enables our state to be able to
do
it enables them to uh
target specific dollars to specific
risk behaviors
and
i think
this suggested amendment is not
uh going to
improve
uh the services
that those agencies do in fact i believe
that it will be detrimental
so my position
if it's an important marker why then do
we object to the elected officials
within that community making that
decision on behalf of parents
again
this is
something that we administer on a
statewide basis
and i believe that it produces
information of value to our state
and
i i think that that amendment
is
is intended
to uh and and the end result would be
less participation
uh and it
will
inhibit the effectiveness of and
validity of the information
that is gathered from the survey
if the school board has responsibility
for approving curriculum used in the
schools which they do have
then why does the school board not have
authority
to decide whether this survey is used or
not used
i i just don't get it for some things
those good elected officials are good
for
and others like this
you will do as you know
as it comes out of doe and doe doesn't
write curriculum
or instruction they do academic
standards yes
so i think there's a disconnect here
between you know local ability to make
these decisions and
and
where we are right now with this statute
yes
represent hops
thank you very much mr chair um
i believe that parents are becoming more
and more intolerant of their children's
information and their family's
information
uh being subjected to public
domains and we have a constitutional
amendment
giving us a right to privacy
so i think it would be beneficial
to
work with parents and school boards
to give them as much information as
possible
so that these students participate in
the programs and in the academic
non-academic surveys
because parents are more and more opting
out that is what i'm hearing
so i i i think the positions are pretty
well known here where we are
um
is there a need for a caucus on the part
on either side i i know there's not on
the house side
caucus yes thank you
welcome back are we ready to progress as
do you have any kind of representative
hennessy senator excuse me well you were
a rep once
mom senator you you left the good side
so we have um
we have some comments on your proposed
agenda
agenda amendment sorry
um we are not opposed to putting
back in the reference to the cdc
in
into
the language
um and we are not opposed to the last
sentence where it says prior to
distribution of the survey students
shall be reminded that the youth risk
survey is voluntary i believe that's in
the instructions for the survey and that
they're already read that
we do have a concern about the local
school district shall annually approve
the risk behavior survey
um
one timing wise
this goes in effect upon passage i don't
know that
the timing wise would be okay two
i don't believe this is administered
annually is that correct i believe it's
every two years
three what happens if the school board
forgets to put it on one of their
agendas but they
do want to administer the survey
to their students because
for example many of the high schools in
my district receive funding to prevent
suicide because the survey has
identified several of my
high schools being
very unfortunately
kids admit that they think about suicide
so if one of my high schools forgets to
approve it at the
school board level then their funding
for suicide prevention would be at risk
so we would prefer that that sentence
not be added into it
but are okay with the other two changes
discussion or response from the
committee members
um
realizing that you know maybe the opt-in
would be an issue for the committee um i
i feel for my support um it would
require local school board approval
and we're willing to take the word
annually out
and put a period right after survey
the local school district shall approve
the youth risk behavior survey
period
uh
again i i think that that is not
acceptable to me i think that
uh
you know it it's not
likely once you lose that
continuity of data
and the data points
uh the value of this goes down
significantly number one on a local
basis and number two
this
does not
provide a statewide view
of
the data
so
i i i think it is not
to me it's not adding value
to
the reason why we do this survey
and so it's not an acceptable change for
me
would the data be changed it would
simply be that the same survey would be
used for
every school district but a approved
upon approval and then that data would
be sent to the department of education
and compiled
so the data is going to be the same data
and hopefully
you would have as many people
participating in as you do now if all
our school boards saw that there's value
to it and
and uh they may hear that type of uh
input from their their membership there
and from
organizations within the community as
we've heard here
well i mean it's a survey right now that
we know very clearly annually
uh when i mean sorry every every two
years when it's administered since 1993
i believe
uh we know that the completion rate on
the survey is 85 to 90 percent
uh
we
this language
inevitably will lead to a less than 85
to 90 percent completion rate across the
state
and that
has a negative impact on the value of
the survey
so
is that a bad thing that if if if a a
local board decides we don't want to a
minute is
i guess that would be the response to
the people that would be a response of
the elected officials in that particular
community that are reflecting the the
input from citizens of that community
if it's something that's a wonderful
thing
and has a lot of merit for the
for the
rationale for giving it uh then uh it
will probably be perceived that way by
the community uh i i can't understand
why if if if we're saying well the the
school board won't do this
but we're going to make them do it
uh
i i i think it's just you know putting
the the elected officials that are been
elected to run that school district in
the back seat of the car
i
missed the back seat of the car metaphor
but uh leaving that aside the
the i mean this this isn't a debate
about local control for me and this is a
debate about
the value of this data on a statewide
basis and i mean if we want to talk
about local control
there were a lot of issues that we could
bring up that came up during this
legislative session where local control
wasn't
a primary
consideration
so
it's that's not it
this is a question for me
about
a completion rate on a statewide basis
that enables
the state to have data
and to
be able to then use that data
to target dollars and requests for
additional funds
to
address specific behaviors identified in
the survey
represent cornelli thank you i would
just say
from
my perspective
uh parental control is a lot more
important than any dollars
involvement
so
is there any further discussion
from the
folks here
the
yes or something represent senator word
excuse me i'm sorry
the people i have spoken with
some of the questions may be
objectionable to some but i think we
have to look at the whole value for the
state for the people who are dealing
with some of the problems that we are
encountering
there are a lot of issues with the teens
and the young people in our state
and if this helps to
figure out where this thing is occurring
what the issues are
i can see this
server being of value there are some
questions in there that i do not like
but i think overall i think we have to
take a look at the what is the big gains
that we can get
further further discussion
representative yeah without the local
control i'm
not for this
so that that is the position of the
house and so if you're non-concurring
with that
uh the the local control
uh i don't think we're going to agree on
anything in this thing
mr do we need to take a vote then on
non-concur or just uh
well
all those that on this on the house side
for non-concur
so there's our
our response
so we would be voting on non-concurring
with the house's position or
we're not going to agree with either one
okay
that's unfortunate i would hope that we
can give our parents some
heads up on these surveys
that was our intent
the current law still stands yeah yeah
so it'd be just as is right now
so with with that that is your response
senator ward from
yes we do not conquer we concur with the
senate version plus with these two
editions that we mentioned
thank you
so with that i think this this uh
committee conference is concluded thank
you very much
thank you
thank you feedback
that's right i don't have to write
anything up either right
senator
good morning to everybody once again
we are now into the third community
conference in this room this morning hb
an act establishing an education freedom
account program administrator in the
department of education and making an
appropriation therefore
we all have a side by side
of the house version and the senate
version
we have in front of us an amendment
which replaces the entire bill
um
i would ask that we
look at that amendment first
and
try to go from there yes um senator
since it's in
[Music]
representative cordelli's name maybe you
would explain it
representative cordelli
not to put you on the spot
not to put me on the spot but
you're on the spot
um
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
yes this uh
uh amendment um is a collaboration
of a number of
stakeholders including the department of
education
was heavily involved in in drafting this
and
tried to do
certain things in this amendment
namely to specify
um
what this program administrator's
position would be
um and you'll see that in line seven of
the amendment it's a level two
administrator
um and then it goes on to try and define
what the duties and responsibilities of
this position um would be
um there had been concern um in
the
prior versions
that had been passed by the house and
senate that it was
kind of open-ended in terms of the
responsibilities of the position might
conflict with the scholarship
organization or organizations
administering the program
and also
[Music]
opened the door for future
um addition of of monies um
under the category of the administrator
so we wanted to tighten that up and not
make it open-ended but
define
what
um
dollars would be associated with this
position um going forward into the
future so i think that that's um
what we tried to do in uh
lines um 12 through 21
and
tighten up what the administration
administrator will do
it had been a problem
we know that this past year was startup
and as always
additional
work required with any startup program
uh
but even going on into the future there
was work that is required both by the
scholarship organization
in the application process
but with the department
as with
any school or program
their responsibility is to make sure
there's no duplication
so that there would be no efa student
who's also listed by a school as being
enrolled in that school
so they do a lot of work in that regard
and um someone is here from the
department if there are any questions
also
um and then the appropriation
is uh online uh starting on line 22
and the money would come out of the
treasury
via warrant by the governor for this
position
and this will take effect july 1 so that
hopefully the person can be hired and
help with
the program um in the fall and the start
of the school year
you could have given us the cliff note
version i'm sorry sorry
uh senator bradley
uh can i ask representative cordelia a
couple of questions
so as i understand that the
rationale for making a general fund
appropriation as opposed to taking it
out of the
10 allocation is that
the 10 allocation is
necessary for a scholarship organization
um to be able to run the program and the
prospect of
not only the administrator but
potentially other future
administrative expenses coming out of
the 10 percent would undermine the
ability
to operate the scholarship organization
is that is that the rationale behind
this
that is part of it
also
when funds are disbursed to an efa
account um the scholarship
organization can withhold uh 10 of that
amount
so um
if
it is required
that
the
cost of this position
come out of that were
basically reducing by a little bit the
money that would go to the efa account
for that student
further
and my understanding is this will
satisfy the
requirement for the department of
education to be able to do what they
need to do
in administering
esa's so
this should be a
well obviously be an ongoing expense but
it won't be
an increasing expense in the future at
least in theory is that correct
uh
that is correct other than any salary
increases that are negotiated right yeah
right yeah um
uh so that you know that's an important
point um and i i think
that
we wanted to avoid
uh any reduction to efa accounts
and that was the reason for the
uh treasury um
source of funding senator prentice oh
thank you chair um cheerlead so uh this
is a question for representative
cordelli or
whoever would like to answer this you
say that they'll
that
using a general fund
using the general fund as the the source
of this appropriation will then
move any burden away potentially from
an individual student's
scholarship correct
okay correct and do we know how much
that is
the scholarship scholarship amounts vary
based on
differentiated aid that the student
might qualify for
um
we have caitlin davis here and caitlin
could give you the specifics on that i
think right and i just want to mention
also in regard to that in terms of the
administrative costs costs
one of the largest
costs to the scholarship organization in
that 10 percent
has been the acquisition
uh of access to a system called class
wallet which tracks all the expenses and
that's like a 30 of their
administrative costs are to pay for
that
system
and
that will be an ongoing expense
per student
and administrative fees on top of that
for use of the class wallet system but
it's integral into the
success of the program and other states
with esa accounts are
moving to
use class wallet or similar systems uh
now also
okay
i would be uh
i'd like to hear from the department on
what they either estimate or know is
going to
be the cost
to each each scholarship i know that you
said they the different ones that there
could be different amounts for
scholarships but i'd like to understand
what that impact is
good morning for the record i'm caitlin
davis from the department of education
um the base efa scholarship amount is
the same amount that just
can you speak a little louder
amplify
the base amount that an efa student is
eligible for is the same amount that
district public school children are
available for which in fiscal year 22 in
fiscal year 23 is
3786 dollars per student
um that's the base amount so the base
amount less the 10
would be i'd like to do the math of my
head but i can't
caleb is a split amongst all the
children so each efa is reduced by 10
percent
um
for up to a maximum of 10
to pay for the administrative set-aside
that goes to the scholarship
organization so three thousand four
hundred and seven dollars is the amount
that would a child would be eligible for
now if a child were additionally
eligible for
um free and reduced lunch aid which is
one thousand eight hundred and ninety
three dollars per kid uh so reduced by
ten percent so another two almost two
hundred dollars and that
instance would be part of the ten
percent that would make up the amount
that the scholarship organization is
eligible to receive to administer the
grants
okay
yeah go ahead
it's more of a statement than a question
but i'll
make i'll share this while you're you're
sitting with us it's been my experience
in in other
say grant programs like federal grant
programs that i have been a part of
receiving and administering whether in
the public or the private sector that
you receive a whole amount and then
there is a percentage of that amount
that you receive
that will go to the administration of
the program so i see this as being
somewhat similar and that is my concern
was my concern on the senate side of
this in in working on how we amended it
and senate education was because that
that to me is part of the the package
you receive it you have your costs for
administration within that
and that though
these things need to be thought about up
front so i just don't think it's an
unusual practice to have a grant have an
administration fee within that grant so
now we're trying to move around the
senate's position and really essentially
backfill the scholarship organization
part of this i don't want children to
have any less than they would have but i
also think that children who are
attending public schools in new
hampshire
have less and are going to continue to
have less if this if we continue down
this pathway that's my position um and i
believe it aligns with the senate
position at least in how we amended this
that's all
thank you
caitlin is it fair to say that of that
10 percent if you don't use it all for
administration the money is plowed back
into future other scholarship awards for
students
i believe it goes back directly to the
student that was reduced by that amount
so not future amounts but the
existing accounts
thanks kaitlyn
thank you are there further questions
for the department
not seeing any thank you
further discussion on this amendment
yes represent mullen thank you very much
and good morning everybody
um
representative cordelli in your
amendment you have uh
sort of cleaned up the job description
if you will for the education freedom
account position
i don't see the word oversight in this
job description anywhere can i assume
is it fair for me to assume them that
roman 3 on line 18
when you say implement policies and
procedures at the department related to
the education freedom account program
that that would include
oversight of
the various touch points that this uh
administrator would have with other
staff
uh yes i believe that that would include
things like the administrative rules
that have been put in place in any
modification of those rules in the
future
related to the program
and i think there's also
in the rsas that we passed related to
this there are
oversight capabilities both for the
department and the legislative committee
as well
thank you
for the questions discussion
um thank you very much mr chair um even
though it is
a different approach than the senate
version for the bill i think that
um representative cordelia has done an
excellent job of outlining
uh the need and how this would function
i
appreciate that representative cordelli
worked with
the education department on this i think
we all knew that
greater oversight will not oversight but
um
administrative
administration of this program was
necessary so the question is how do you
pay for it i think that
you know where this might be somewhat
different than
you know the circumstance that
um
senator apprentice was talking about is
the point that was just made
any savings in the 10
goes back to the individual kid and so
therefore i i think i can accept the
house position on this
understanding that we all saw that there
was a need for the administrator
position
and i can accept the funding
proposed in here because
any excess dollars go back to the kids
so i i think glenn you did an excellent
job
this uh was done i believe we had a
two-hour meeting over at granite state
with folks with the department
and there's a lot of discussion a lot of
plowing around trying to figure out
to get away from the laundry list but to
get into specifics it's kind of
summarize it and i think that you're
correct senator i think this is a good
general overview of the program and will
get us on the road to having
some coordination from the department
itself
in the efi program
further discussion
from the committee
so are we at the position where we need
uh senator ward to have uh
whoever's in charge over there
uh george
to have a vote on the part of uh each
particular group
the house
representative weiler is talking about
lunch here
so
okay what we're going to do is get back
to business here on the bill itself
uh mr chairman yes can i just have an
opportunity just to make a statement
before we do this you may um i
understand that the senate removed the
direct certification to medicaid portion
of the bill that arrived before them
and uh
while i'm not
questioning the decision of the senate i
would just like to make mention of the
fact that
feeding hungry children is
an issue
that we need to confront in new
hampshire and it has come before
at least the house
multiple times over the past couple of
years and
while i understand that there were some
concerns about the sort of trial aspect
of the direct certification process
i would like to see us taking an active
role in feeding hungry children moving
forward
thank you
yeah there's a lot to that whole program
we're talking about and
okay uh let's get back on to this bill
now thank you very much representative
mullen um
we're we're looking at the amendment
2033-h
that would replace 1627
uh
after the enacting flaws
so uh
representative senator apprentice
assistance for uh representative mullen
who's also a sue made a statement i'd
just like to make a brief one that i am
going to support this and i'm going to
support this because it will go back
to the children um as has been explained
in you know into their scholarship funds
so i i will move with the group on that
but i just wanted to put that on the
record and appreciate the um the
collegial and informative conversation
that we've just had thank you thank you
that's for
you that live right down the valley from
me
neighbors neighbors
thank you uh
senator uh
has the senate taking a position on this
2033 okay
and and we do too so i guess we are at
the common point we want to be at thumbs
up and
we will close this uh this community
conference we have now approved the
amended version of 1627
thank you very much
sure
i opened the
meeting of the committee of conference
on house bill 1662
we had uh presentations on the first
three of the four items and i would like
to call on senator birdsell to
speak to the fourth item requiring third
party sellers to provide certain
information to online marketplaces and
to consumers and so on
thank you representative
this is a bill that was brought to us um
and it passed out of the senate i
believe on a voice vote um
and
what the problem is
it's a nationwide problem so far we have
the two latest states that have passed
this bill
have been
georgia and illinois
we also have i believe colorado alabama
and what it does is it um
the problem that's been happening is
it's a 500 billion dollar problem in
this country where
uh you've been hearing about the uh
smashing grabs
um a lot of these places are doing smash
and grabs they're selling this stuff on
online marketing
and what this bill does is it requires
the online marketers only
to
vet their third party providers to make
sure that they are
legitimate
um third-party vendors for them
in july 18 2019
for those that don't believe it happens
in new hampshire
detectives in manchester netted more
than 400 pieces of new box products
including tools and electronics which
were reportedly stolen several of the
criminals involved in the organized
retail crime scheme would sell the
stolen products online for profit so
this does happen in new hampshire
and what it does what the bill does is
require that the third party sellers
who fit the definition of the bill of
high volume meaning they make 200 or
more transactions sell more than five
thousand dollars worth of new
merchandise um
they need to be vetted and basically
getting their it requires online
marketer to collect information from the
third parties such as their
their
taxable information their address and a
contact number the other thing this bill
will will provide
is cover for the for the attorney
general in their consumer protection
arena so that when they go to the third
party if they get complaints
of 30 on
the online marketers
the ag can subpoena or can get that
information
as long as new hampshire has passed the
law
um the ag will be able to um
get that information from the online
marketers without that informa without
the bill passing the um there's a good
chance that the online marketers do not
have to provide that information
what it also does
is
besides snap
smash and grabs
they're also now selling
counterfeit prescription drugs on some
of these online marketing
sites
they're also starting to sell some of
the um counter
[Music]
baby formulas
and things that are online so
this is a
pretty much a consumer protection
um but it all doesn't require us to do
anything it does require the online
marketers to do it um some of the online
marketers are doing it on their own
some are not
um this is a bill that
um we amended it to match the language
that the feds have
um but this a lot of the states are
trying to push it through their states
because they don't trust the feds to be
able to get it through
and this is a protection for our
constituents so with that mr chair i
will um
entertain any questions
i'm wondering how do we enforce it i
know there's been some times when
there's been a a problem with an
out-of-state bank and we learned that we
really couldn't do anything because it
was out of state uh what if one of these
online platforms is cited in another
state
somebody in new hampshire may buy off
that platform but how do we have
jurisdiction to go after them
we don't
it's up to the marketing
the online marketer to police their own
what happens is the attorney general
will get complaints
and then they will go
ask the online marketer in amazon or a
home depot or a walmart
for the information on that third party
and what
should this bill this part of the bill
pass
um
who sues whom
who
penalizes whom if it isn't done
i'm presuming the a.g would go after the
third-party event try and go after the
third party vendor if there are enough
complaints in new hampshire
if the third party vendors company is
registered in let's say michigan and has
a home office in say maryland or so on
and the only
connection to new hampshire is somebody
in new hampshire went online and bought
a product and got it in the mail
how can we
do anything to these people
i'm
you could bring um jim demers up here
yeah jim information come on up mr
demers
thank you mr chairman um so for the
record my name is james demers and my
client that has been involved in this is
walmart
um so
i think what you're referencing is the
commerce clause which
does impede states ability to prevent
out-of-state businesses like banks from
doing certain things in new hampshire
but it does not impede
our consumer protection act
and in fact our attorney general could
go after
one of these platforms if it's located
out of state so they do have the ability
to cross jurisdictions in order to take
action because the transaction occurred
with a new hampshire resident
being a party to it
but i do recall also
during the house commerce hearing
the attorney general saying that
at least two of the biggest platforms
do have a new hampshire nexus so walmart
has brick and mortar stores in new
hampshire
and amazon has warehouse facilities in
new hampshire
which would give him even additional
jurisdiction
to enforce the law
any further questions
yes representative edwards
uh this is for the senator if you'll
take my question um so so i have
constituents that would say to me
that um
if we want small limited government we
should not be growing government
we should not be having increasing a
regulatory environment for our
businesses
and that this bill would be inflationary
how would you respond to those three
concerns
well first of all it doesn't grow
government because the ag is capable of
handling the the situation that has as
it is
um
we have many um
commerce protect our um
consumer protection laws
and why would this be any different we
have people that are being harmed we
have businesses and and forget the
people the customers who buy off of
these online marketing what about the
businesses i mean we have um home depot
in
nashua just lost a million dollars in
smashing grabs and stealing many of
these products are going to be caught
are online so in essence we're already
paying for this
this is a way to protect both our
businesses and our consumers
any other questions for the senator
about this yes uh representative
turcotte
thank you mr chairman uh just looking at
the sheet of paper that was
handed out and also according to the
senator's last
statement talking about smash and grabs
it looks like
the organized real tale crime at least
in new hampshire the majority of these
are
thefts
from brick and mortar whether or not
that stuff ends up online
during my discussions kind of irrelevant
the point i mean
i'm gonna make is if these are smashing
grabs or if there's just a ring of going
into these stores home depot whatever
is that not
a
an issue for stos
excuse me store security and
theft
prevention i mean all these here look to
be in that category at least in new
hampshire
so
i'm not so sure my my mind has been
changed that
this is probably not something that we
need
but thank you
well
if you don't think some of these things
that i mean we do have i just stated
that the
um
that in manchester in um 2019 400 pieces
of new box products including tools and
electronics
were reportedly stolen several of the
criminals involved in the organized
retail crime scheme would sell the
stolen products online for profit if you
don't think that
um
cri the organized retail crime is not
being sold online then i've got a bridge
in brooklyn to sell you
and i don't disagree that some of that
stuff
ends up online what i am saying is going
back to my original point
why were 400 pieces of new box products
including tools and electronics allowed
to be stolen
from uh from a store where's the
you know where's the store security
where's uh the involvement with the
police there's another one here
talking about the perfume in nashua
where the retail crime manager
recognized one of the three caught on
footage noting he's an extensive history
of theft i mean
um
so you're blaming the victim at this
point
i'm blaming the
the stores who are
having their
their stuff stolen from why aren't they
putting more
policies procedures or whatever in
security to prevent this stuff from
happening in the first place a lot of
these stores are being held at gunpoint
it's a 500 billion dollar
market for this
and many of the ones in the larger
stores some of the employees are being
held at gunpoint i'm not sure that any
store security would be able to handle
that kind of
assault
representative edwards
at the risk of
of my getting myself confused what what
i think the point of this paper is
is to
highlight the fact that there are
thefts
taking place in new hampshire and that
these items may well end up in an online
transaction but what your bill does
is that
it goes to the marketplace the online
marketeer
and holds them accountable for
maintaining records on
who enters their online market from a
supplier perspective if they're of a
sufficient size
so so
so this paper isn't
directly correlated to your bill other
than to say
that this sort of crime exists and this
is a way
that the illicit suppliers get their
inventory
that is correct all right thank you i
saw a television clip of two carloads of
bad guys all masked and everything
and
they
very quickly took out the front window
of a high-end jewelry store and then
crashed into all the cabinets and just
scooped stuff up and put them in bags
and they were gone
in less than a minute
now there's
two ways to deal with this because this
is obviously very important the
merchant has lost merchandise his
insurance payments will go up he's had
his store damaged uh if he's going to
stay in business he will have to charge
more money out of the pockets of
innocent consumers
it's two ways to go after these people
number one is at the at the level of the
local police do we have footage do we
have cameras taking license plates not
in new hampshire but in other states do
we have a way of going after the bad
guys that's one way secondly
when they try to sell the stuff online
your bill does not deal with every
aspect of organized crime but it deals
with one important thing that's been
somewhat neglected in my opinion
and i might add to that um
in years past they have found that i
think in one of the articles i read they
have found that um pawn brokers in in
the past used to they used to do the
same thing with pawn brokers they have
come down and they have put rules and
regulations in with pawn brokers to
i won't say eliminate but help
help eliminate some of the issues this
is similar to what they're doing to try
and
stop ahead of time any people that would
be going um doing these smash and grabs
and doing and selling them online
representative turcotte
thank you uh mr chairman would this
apply uh senator to
things like craigslist facebook
or is this strictly an amazon related
big major online marketplaces my
understanding is craigslist is not
included in this
the chair would like to recognize to
speak curtis barry who is a subject
matter expert on this to answer that
question
i can recognize you behind your mask
the orange badge was a giveaway
thank you mr chair i think you're
building too high of expectations for me
but um
to answer that question directly in the
bill in the language uh there are two
definitions if you will two thresholds
one for the online marketplace one for
the
the seller i think as already recognized
the seller needs to have sold
uh made 200 or more transactions and
word and not or and five thousand
dollars worth of transactions in a
12-month period to fall under the bill
on the marketplace
in essence it it only applies to
marketplaces that facilitate the
financial transaction
so as i've explained
to folks on this bill before
if i'm selling on craigslist and i sell
my basketball hoop to representative
edwards
uh he's going to come to my home with
his pickup truck we're going to exchange
cash
the marketplace does not facilitate the
transaction in that place so craigslist
is out what's in is where the
marketplace does facilitate that
financial transaction
okay
any other questions of
so i think you used an and statement
that it's 200 transactions and
5 000
within 12 months correct
that that that doesn't feel like
that seems slow to me like why is why
aren't we talking a thousand
twenty thousand why it seems like maybe
we've got a bigger net here than what's
needed how did those two numbers get
picked for the
size of the supplier so representative
edwards that decision those
decisions on the terminology or the
language in this particular bill were
decided well above me and well outside
of new hampshire
around the time of the senate hearing
this year on this bill in fact in a
matter of a week or so
there was agreement among parties
relative to the federal language and as
senator birdsell referenced earlier this
language what you have before you
mirrors what's um what was agreed upon
in federal language so i can't speak to
the wise wherefores of those numbers
other than to say
it wanted to recognize folks that are
high volume sellers without getting
too ridiculously high to capture you
know virtually no one
thank you
the language would be pretty much the
same in this wonderful map i have here
some of which
are states that have already it's in law
now there are six states where this is
enacted of five of those uh are this
calendar year i believe uh and the
balance of those that has passed at
least one legislative body yes and the
language is consistent with what we have
here
yes okay thank you
thank you
i'd like to do a sense of the room on
this point only um
senate
this is just a straw poll it isn't
locking us into anything
i'm supporting it
so you like it because you sent it to us
right good thank you
and how about us
i believe
i think we did this yesterday i think um
we did here here's my points um
while i don't disagree there there are
issues out there um this came out of
commerce with an interim study i have
great faith in representative hunt
we listened to a very
uh rambunctious discussion yesterday
during the uh
small break
um
and
i just think that there's the federal uh
potential out there
again i'm
not being an expert in this um and not
on this committee for this particular
piece i i have to rely on representative
hunt i know he is certainly still
uh for the interim study part of this
um
so at this point i'm i still know on it
thank you
can i just add something please do so
and i i understand the concern and that
it goes into
that the fed the feds however if we're
going to wait for the feds to do
something to help our constituents and
our businesses
we may be waiting a long time
senator i
seem to recall please help me if i
recall accurately
that if
the feds
get around to passing this kind of bill
it will a be
for the whole country of course
and b anything that we do here will
quickly sunset
so if they're going to move quickly
wonderful it'll sunset soon
if they're not
may we not need this
if they're just not going to get off the
dime
okay
so
it looks like
uh we do not have unanimity
in the house
i would love to know what you think i
always love to know what you think
i i have no passion for this bill it
sounds like a
a reasonable effort to uh protect
consumers um
i uh
if if if the cost of getting my dhhs
privacy bill
passed uh is this
component of the agreement i i'm i'm in
favor of it otherwise i'm like i have no
independent passion for it
okay it's hard to sustain the passion on
one house member but there it is
now i need to ask this question that i
asked yesterday that now that we've had
time to think it through
is the senate's position
on this bill with its four parts
all or nothing or are you willing to
vote on each section separately
thank you for the uh thank you for the
question mr chair it's
these are all bills that
the senate
attached to this house bill
we would like to see them i think we've
made
great arguments as to why they should
pass
we're not going to vote on these
individually we will vote on them as one
all or nothing all or nothing okay
representative edwards
um given given that that's the case uh
i'm a no uh because i this uh
the 5 million for the homeless
project uh i i just can't support it
it was a bill that the senate passed and
tabled and didn't send the house for the
house to have its due process around hhs
committee and division three
we're in the middle of a budget year
the governor's about to start his budget
year in a few months
and this is a good candidate for that
but if
the cost of getting my privacy bill
passed is the 5 million for the homeless
then i would rather have neither
so i'm seeing
pretty much know
and representative turcotte thank you mr
chairman um yeah as a whole no
representative edwards made
the exact point i would make on that
particular piece of the bill
um
and the other part that i discussed in
detail yet uh yesterday was the uh
the pay cards which i think i
made the
promise to the senators that i believe
we should work together next fall to
come up with something
that's much more business friendly and
much more easier
and less regulation so i don't believe
that should remain in there either and
then we've just spoken about the last
part so no i would be you know
so it looks like our conclusion then
without objection is the bill has failed
okay yes
we're done
you